behind the net your tried to slide it ahead
wearing that familiar 55 in his previous five
games of the National Hockey League shot
from the wing there by Guston wide easy a
healthy scratch the other night gets into the
lineup cross ice pass a redirected it's one
nothing gustofson Let It Go from the point
it was redirected right in FR of murans and
the New York Rangers Strike early 50 seconds
in you got to just shake it off it goes off
Blue Jackets defenseman in front of the net
might be prover off no it's a far side it's
the Winger there as the Blue Jackets are nice
and low you can see guson just trying to go
across ice and it's Foody and there's nothing
M leans or the Blue Jackets players can do he
just have to Simply Shake by marchenko fights
it off and the Rangers will come out to here
is Center Panera right wing Mara sand in front
shot and a goal Elvis down and Roofing it there
but impressive width passing and then how about
that pass by Guston who's got the goal already
but now that that skat's hovering it above the
line that would negate it there's a review cam
looks like that Pucks in now if we focus on
left from near I think he had control when he
brought that puck over you can see the skates
right here behind the line the pucks already
in sorry about my doy drawings after review it's
confirmed that the player was offside no goal oh
good shurin sends it up the boards it's off left
and year to the Columbus end Adam bis sends it
high Deep In the Zone here now Schneider takes
a hit from in front Marko throws it jacket and
tied it up what a play by jko along the wall
four assists all of last season tell you what
he's going to challenge it now that's number two
in the early season and a great play by Mar they
do a good job figuring out get that puck to the
middle of the ice and it starts with Jenner little
shoulder check he goes inside outside to make sure
they're forcing that puck off the boards see here
he's on the inside of the hip pushes that puck
off the boards and then marenko knows he's got
Johnny goodro at the net puts the pressure on and
Bo Jenner standing right there at the top of the
circle he made the right decision there he's going
against one of the most physical defenseman in the
NHL in Jacob trouba here the puck turned over
shot and a goal zabad on the turnover Abad and
there this puck just doesn't get high enough
and look at all that time and space for mik
Advantage he's got a really long stick it's with
the player the ranger is in the zone so that means
another goal should be coming back I mean we're
not we don't have the angle right here here's
the angle now I can't that puck you can see the
the dark spot on the white board so we're going
to get a judgment right now after video review was
determined that the play was offside therefore we
have the 194 tell he just unloads that puck with
a good heavy shot you're right he's quick to make
that decision here he is turning Ry oh by the
puck is in the net yes it is a goal the referee
motioning gets a piece of him now tro identifies
that puck going towards the goal line here he goes
oh boy pu did not completely cross it's been a
period of reviews here third review third one
gone Johnson less than 30 seconds left proov
looks to the left wing Prov Rob now will drill
it jackets feed the point marenko Kent Johnson
right Circle back here to proov screen set in
front of sh sturen and it's power play goal
from up high the Blue Jackets finally and the
Blue Jackets moving things around keep an eye on
38 he staying right in front of eigor shurin and
on this one he backs off he sets himself off to
the side for a pass and here's the Pass Perfect
in the air and there's Boon stick on Puck and no
chance for E going sterkin he's fronting the puck
and boom just off to the side and up he'll set
it to the right Point Long Shot there blocked
in front of shurin good save there at the line
by Jake Bean who's dancing up high he'll fire a
shot scor Jake B just let one through and the
Blue Jackets now lead by two boom Jenner with
a hattick the natural hattick for the young man
Puck is going to come through as Jake Bean gets
it he's going to take the players down low that
creates all that ice up top enables him to get
on his forehand and as he sails it through Igor
shurin is tracking this Puck high and as he is
there's Boon Jenner with the perfect deflection
pass eagor textbook that stick has to be below
the crossbar on go and right there looks like
it's just at the crossbar and Boon cheddar
great start to the season for Boon picked up a
hattick with redirected by the Jackets captain
and until he plays it Off the Wall he'll throw
it behind the net shurin along the wall shot
quickly he'll make a bad save there brovero
dishing late turns looks up high top of the
circle shot scores yurich his first National
Hockey League goal his first NHL point for
the National Hockey League nice job by Patrick l
here you can see David very composed as he gets
it Mak sure he's set and boy beautiful shot just
over the glove of eigor shurin that'll be one he
never forgets first goal in the National Hockey
League or David Ur I like that celebration David
oh Ling could not play the puck gon will step up
and dump in deep Martin out of the net lineing to
the line but not out dson tro quick shot scores
KY as we mentioned 24 goals last year in Harford
earning a spot in training camp former second
round pick it's 4-2 quick play at the line for the
New York Rangers they keep the puck in you can see
Lon trying to knock that puck out of the air it's
two little passes about an 8 foot and then a 4ot
pass and coie who led the American League Harford
wolf pack last year in goals he gets his Puck and
just rips it didn't waste any time and that beats
Martin and now we got a 4-2 game here effectively
to his stick he'll get it though dishing Long
Shot jackets block that doing a terrific job
in front of their goal tender and now Cole
CER on a breakaway moves in scores on the feed
Justin dadf forth takes the cylinder pass it's
52 by Kent Johnson here our kmy paner is the
last guy back he's going to rush Johnson and
Johnson says thank you very much I'm going
to lay this in front of singer Dan forth
on his forehead first of the season that's
got to feel good for him coming off a long
rehab Cinder does a good job here slides
it across Danforth goes upstairs that's
a beauty that makes it it's 52 back on his
feet shot sails wide of Spencer Martin and
on in relief out M leens here in the third
period now Fox top of the circle right side
Martin the save rebound scores it went in
off the leg of good Branson so 36 seconds
left and then ends up beating Spencer Martin
there's that puck off of him that rebound
you can see as cder just chops at it and he
get up goals on that blue paint consistently
and this one is just stick on Puck he
wins that race to get it there and good
Branson it goes off of his Shimp paded
end so with and now cherson will clear
and that'll do it the Columbus Blue Jackets
file Off the Bench Boon Jenner the hattrick